amazon founder jeff bezos is getting
ready to ride his own rocket into space
he says he'll go on the first passenger
flight in a blue origin capsule next
month
he's also taking his brother and is
auctioning off
a third seat to the highest bidder
well dw reporter peter rollerdale's been
keenly observing mr bezos
extraterrestrial ambitions welcome peter
uh so the astronomically wealthy jeff
bezos now officially heading for the
stars
yeah i mean this may go down as one of
the coolest
gifts not just on earth but beyond
taking his brother there on this trip
uh historic trip to space um it's the
first ever crude flight
of the new shepherd and that's the
rocket ship made by basos own space
company the blue origin
and it's a fully autonomous rocket
meaning that there's no pilot flying
this thing
it will take six passengers more than 60
miles that's about
100 kilometers above earth into what is
called sub-orbital space and that's just
high enough
for the passengers to experience a few
minutes of weightlessness and
to look out of these huge beautiful
windows to see the curvature of the
planet
uh before the capsule returns to earth
and the entire flight
shouldn't take a lot more than 11
minutes from start to finish
all right and that's going to be one of
the most expensive 11 minutes uh
in the world he's auctioning off one of
the seats
presumably because he needs the money
exactly exactly that's what's amazing
um the price tag for this is currently
at over three million dollars that's
the highest bid right now and that's
five almost 500 000 more
than just a few hours ago you know the
bidding really soaring
after bezos there announced that he will
be going on this trip as well
and this is really all part of you know
the big billionaire space scramble that
we've seen in recent years and decades
with some of the world's richest men uh
launching their own space
startups you know from richard branson
with his
uh virgin galactic to tesla founder elon
musk's
spacex and they're just pumping these
astronomical sums of money into a very
niche market
that's based towards them it is a
booming industry that is fueled by
the ultra wealthy and we're all itching
to become part of the
60 mile high club well if you say so um
i'm boycotting it personally
um is it like is he not making enough
money here on earth jeff bezos
well i think what unites this enterprise
is not just that
they're all run by billionaires but also
ostensibly
that they have a very strong focus on
sustainability you know
launching a rocket into space is not
something most people would associate
with
you know carbon friendly um
but these rockets are revolutionary
revolutionary in the sense that they are
reusable and it appears that at least
part of what's driving
this push is a heightened awareness
among these billionaires
of our unique place in the universe in
our desire to protect the planet and
here's how
jeff bezos himself is describing that
you see the earth from space and it
changes you it changes your relationship
with this planet with humanity
it's one earth you know that's an opal
sentiment but it's also one that many
will see us further prove that besos
just does not live in the same reality
as the rest of us again the current high
bid standing at over 3
million dollars for many like bezos who
last year made
more than 10 billion dollars in a single
day that's pocket change but
for the rest of us it's a reminder that
while we may live on the same planet
we don't live in the same sphere yeah
you say that i think i'm going to
withdraw my bid now i'm not convinced
peter rollerdale thank you
you